a very good evening thank you for
joining us the UK will be the world's
only major economy to shrink this year
the assessment from the international
monetary fund which even puts sanction
hit Russia ahead of Britain in 2023.
they blame the UK's tighter monetary and
fiscal policies number 10 says the
economy is strong well coming up we'll
be picking apart that report and seeing
how it will affect us all with the
leading macro economic Economist a
personal finance expert and our
economics and data editor Ed Conway but
first Ed has tonight's first report
Tuesday lunchtime inside one of London's
most prestigious restaurants normally
this place is packed
today they aren't even serving lunch
just preparing for the evening but
normally obviously if the lunch was
happening this would be we would be in
lunch service now yeah okay yeah the
problem isn't so much demand people
still want to eat out it's that amongst
other things restaurants like this can't
get the staff if I advertise what I get
now is I get four or five CVS from
abroad mostly from the EU
people who I can't employ
if we could have full employment all of
those people would be generating
National Insurance income tax the vat
that you know on the cup of coffee that
you buy on your way to the train station
in the morning
um that all generates wealth and that
wealth is not being generated because we
can't operate at full capacity
extrapolate this across the country and
you start to see why the international
monetary fund is so pessimistic about
the UK's prospects
back in October they thought economic
growth the red bar here would be
somewhere in the middle of the
industrialized pack this year its new
forecasts paint a far gloomier picture
the UK the weakest not just in the
developed world but of any country
mentioned by the fund including Russia
why its Chief Economist says it's partly
those labor shortages partly higher
taxes partly brexit and partly higher
energy costs we've had a very sharp
increase in in natural gas prices Energy
prices in the UK and there is a larger
share of energy that is coming from from
natural gas with a higher pass through
to to final consumers and so that is
affected there's been a stronger cost of
living crisis if you want in uh in the
UK but has the fund gone a bit too far I
think it's a little bit too negative
given the state of the economy it's
saying that the UK will perform at the
bottom of the G7 in those terms I don't
think that's where we're going to sit
we're going to sit in the middle of the
pack now this is just a forecast it'll
probably end up being wrong and it
doesn't change much in practice life the
economy the cost of living crisis it all
goes on as it was pretty much before but
it is awfully awkward for the
governments only a week or two ago the
treasury was saying that the IMF its
forecast well part of the reason the UK
wasn't alone in facing tough Economic
Times now we are very much alone at the
very bottom of those League tables
on the third anniversary of brexit
Britain is still waiting for the green
shoots of economic recovery and with the
rest of the world now forecast to
recover patience is beginning to run
thin
well here to discuss this further and
unpack exactly what this report means
for all of us is our economics editor Ed
Conway and we're also joined by a former
Chief Economist at the international
monetary fund Kenneth rogoff who is now
a professor of Economics at Harvard
University and Laura souter head of
personal finance and investment platform
AJ Bell a very warm welcome to you all
thank you for joining us let's speak to
you first Ed a look at the big picture
and all the numbers here when you look
at this IMF report the UK really is in a
very poor position isn't it yeah I mean
it's it's awkward and it's embarrassing
because you know previously everyone was
doing quite badly but we were kind of
somewhere in the middle of the pack
whereas now we're just a bit of an
outlier and when you look I mean I think
we can show you that this this chart
here when you look at the whole array of
different countries kind of around the
world
um we are there on the far right hand
side and the fact that we're kind of
below well Germany but the fact that
we're below Russia you know Russia where
sanctions uh which has been imposed with
sanctions at the moment which has seen
an enormous fall in its economic growth
that just underlines just how I guess
humiliating is for the UK government but
you just have to kind of step back and
ask the broader question you know first
of all there is a question as to whether
these are just forecasts okay this
doesn't necessarily mean that anyone's
life is going to change it's just a bet
on where we are heading and the verdict
is not particularly flattering for the
UK it might well be that you know
because what's happened in practice here
is the UK has been downgraded partly
reflecting the fact that we are weaker
than people the IMF thought last time
around remember that since then they've
had to reflect that we had the mini
budget you had all of those roller
coasters that we had after that and the
fact that this government under British
sunak under Jeremy Hunt is starting to
kind of contract uh the public finances
there's a lot that's kind of gone on
since that the IMF is catching up with
the question I think and we don't know
the answer to this is whether they've
been a little bit optimistic about
places like Germany and Italy because
you've had Energy prices not affecting
them quite as much as expected mites you
know we get an upgrade later on in the
spring I think it's quite plausible but
even when you kind of take a step back
we're not in a very good position there
are all sorts of factors that are
weighing on the UK economy right now
you've got whether whether it's brexit
whether it's what's going on in the
labor market where people are really
struggling to get you know kind of find
to find staff whether it's what's going
on with fiscal tightening whether taxes
are rising whether you've got the
interest rates going up the cost of
living crisis more broadly in inflation
put all of that together and it kind of
adds up to things not feeling very good
at the moment the question as to whether
the UK really is quite as much of an
outlier as that chart and the numbers
from the IMF suggest I think that's an
open one you know things don't look
necessarily very good do they look quite
as abysmal as we see in that chart I
think we'll have to wait and see but
certainly in the imf's October forecast
it was the third if Global economies and
now it's yeah exactly and I think that's
the thing is it's just it's all good for
the government because they used to you
know literally when I was talking to
Jeremy Hunt about this not long ago and
he said well yes we're not doing that
great but look the IMF says that a third
of the global economy is facing
recession at the moment now that third
suddenly looks like pretty much no one
apart from us and so it's difficult
presentationally for him yeah I mean the
Optics are not great uh but as you say
it is it is a forecast let's bring in uh
Kenneth now if I I may as a former
former Economist at the IMF it'd be very
interesting to to get your take on that
and just further to what Ed and I were
discussing there the UK has has the UK
government has long been saying this is
a global problem but this report today
no longer reflects that
well I think I mean Ed said it really
well that it's just a forecast so uh the
odds that the UK actually ends up last
you know maybe aren't so high uh to me
when I read the report I mean the thing
that's stuck stuck out for the rest of
the world was how optimistic it was it
was quite a turn even from the World
Bank three weeks ago had given a darker
report
um I was in Davos and it was also very
euphoric I I think it's hard to like
parse exactly what the issue is in the
UK I mean clearly the monetary type
thing fiscal tightening uh the gas
prices the consumer had not been
protected as much in some other
countries uh but I I think it's hard to
avoid that brexit is a part of this
that's why it's so hard to find EU
workers there are other parts that are
just hard to know the UK has had less of
a return to work than say my country the
United States has where a lot of people
sort of sat out during covet but have
been gradually coming back and that has
not happened so much in the UK and then
lastly there's just this long-term you
know productivity uh disappointment
again and again productivity is how much
you produce with the capital and labor
you have so there's sort of a lot of
Legacy problems uh but it's certainly uh
you know not a pretty picture for the UK
for this year
yeah and and Laura just on to you now
it's really interesting what Kenneth was
saying there about how a large uh
section of the workforce just hadn't
returned uh to the labor market uh since
the pandemic what are you hearing from
people about the cost of living and the
struggles that they're having are in a
problems here worse than in other
countries in terms of people being able
to make ends meet
yeah so I think actually the cost of
living crisis is something that's
pushing more people back into work we
saw this great kind of retirement of
over 50s during the pandemic who decided
to take early retirement we're now
actually seeing some of those come back
in but not in the largest ways that the
government would like and partly that's
because they've realized that with the
cost of living crisis and the rising
prices of things they can't afford
necessarily to be in retirement for as
long as they were planning the other
side of this that we have is um lots of
people who are off long term sick and so
these are people who don't feel well
enough to go back into work which
presents another challenge for the
government as to how to get those people
back um being economically active as
they would say or back in employment
and kind of just um to you again if I
may as someone who used to work at the
IMF the IMF made all of these gloomy
predictions uh after brexit about the
economy uh some of which didn't
materialize
um we didn't actually see proper
contraction until covid so in in light
of that how seriously should we take
this forecast today
it's a very tough to do forecasting when
you're coming out of the pandemic which
we hadn't seen in a hundred years when
we have this tightening of interest
rates around the world which we haven't
seen in 40 years there's a lot of
uncertainty and did I mention the war in
Russia and Ukraine uh where it's very
very unpredictable so it's tough uh it
is also true we you mentioned uh the
brexit if we go back to the global
financial crisis the IMF actually
consistently over predicted the whole
world except for the United Kingdom
where it said it would do badly and it
didn't do as badly but you know who
knows
well someone who often knows the answer
to many things has said well our
encyclopedia Ed but you have a question
for Kenneth I was gonna Ken I was going
to ask I mean obviously as someone who's
who's been in charge of some of these
forecasts in the past they can be quite
contentious can't they and so you know
what what's happening can you paint a
picture of what happens behind the
scenes you know when for instance you
know the UK sees that it's gonna have
this grizzly forecast is there lots of
stuff that happens lots of lobbying
behind the scenes that can actually
influence the way these things go
because obviously there's a big
political political implication back
here you know we're talking about this
it's Front Page News what's happening
over there are they conscious of how big
of a deal this stuff is
well I'm sure they are because
singled out speaking about the United
Kingdom you know when I was at the IMF
which was a long time ago uh the the
country analysts which are often uh
talking to the governments the different
governments tended to be a little
optimistic and the job of putting it all
together would be well okay you're being
really optimistic given that interest
rates are going up and inflation is high
for example and you try to kind of
square the circle and you know sometimes
it comes out more on one country than
another uh we were I think tough on the
United States during my period uh I
think there's also kind of a need for
the IMF to beat up on at least one
developed economy because it's always
beating up on Emerging Markets but I I
think the UK sort of stands out with the
problems that it's had there's brexit
I don't know what to make of it but the
financial explosion last year if I got
the numbers right for chancellors in
four months is sort of sticking your
neck out to get picked on
yeah some of the UK statistics haven't
been haven't been the best recently
Kenneth that's that's for sure Laura
to you next the obr made a similar a
downbeat assessment of the UK economy
last week how much do these Bleak
forecasts impact investors and consumer
spending
so I think they certainly are not going
to encourage those people who've perhaps
got savings they're not going to
encourage them to start splurging their
money if they're worried about things
like recession
um the potential of losing their job it
puts people in a very fearful
environment and lots of the things that
these forecasters are talking about are
things that people are really feeling
every day so it's things like the impact
of the mini budget the disastrous mini
Budget on mortgage rates and people
coming to remortgage now facing so much
higher cost from that it's the higher
energy cost translating through to
People's Energy bills we have figures
out again today on food inflation being
over 16 it's those massive costs that
people are feeling at the same time as
the bank of England is Raising interest
rates and come April we're going to have
a raft of tax rises from the government
or at least stealth tax Rises by them
not increasing allowances by so much all
of that put together is not an
environment that makes people feel like
they want to be going out and smashing
the cash and spending lots of money
either in restaurants or or buying items
it's not a positive spending environment
for those people who even have spare
cash at the moment which of course lots
of people don't
uh and Kenneth one of one of the
policies being considered uh By Number
10 is giving companies in incentives to
invest in the UK and penalizing those
that don't is that an effective way of
boosting growth do you think
well I have to say uh what the United
States did with its so-called inflation
reduction Act was basically doing that
you got a subsidy to do certain kinds of
investment in the United States Korean
but not everything green and that's
really been sucking investment away from
the UK and from all of Europe and to the
extent you're doing something like that
to maybe push green investment I think
labor has pushed that idea you know it's
sort of an industrial policy but many
countries are doing it I think one of
the issues obviously and I defer to
everyone else here on that but is that
if you're trying to get somebody to
invest more in the UK but the current
government's trailing massively in the
polls and thinks they might be out
you're kind of might be looking past
them to see what labor is going to do
and what their policies are which which
seem very Centrist and accurate to me by
the way from what I've seen scene but
it's hard to kind of move the needle a
lot when they know you're might not be
there in a couple years
if I may I mean the recession is
predicted to be shallow less Grim than
2008 is there anything positive or any
little light at the end of the tunnel
that you can you can leave us with
tonight I mean it's not so so it may not
I mean it may be a recession it may be a
very shallow recession it's not it's not
the kinds of recessions we've
experienced recently it's nothing like
what happened after cover there's
nothing like the financial crisis at
least as far as these forecasts go and
and it's quite unusual actually for for
anyone like the bank of England or the
IMF or any of these people to forecast a
recession it's just because Energy
prices are so high in interest rates are
so high you just plug that into your
model and you get something that looks
like a recession but to go back to what
what cam rogoff was saying it is a
really interesting moment right now
because you've got the US basically
throwing money at their economy throwing
money at Green Industries in an
extraordinary way in an extraordinary
way that the likes of which in the US at
least we haven't seen for decades and
the Striking thing about this moment
right now and this matters for jobs it
matters for you know for livelihood
across this country it matters for the
economy is that the UK doesn't really
have a response to that right now the EU
you know we were in Davos not long ago
the EU was going on about this the US is
spending all this money we need to come
up with something the UK just doesn't
really have any kind of strategy on it
at the moment and it's hard to tell
whether it's because it's thought about
it because it's decided it doesn't
really want to have a strategy because
it just wants us take a step back or or
what but this is really consequential
stuff we are living potentially right
now through another Industrial
Revolution and the question of who gets
ahead of this is really big and the us
right now rightly or wrongly is going
all guns blazing into this it's trying
to catch up with China the EU is trying
to chase them where does the UK stand on
that that could determine what happens
with jobs it can determine with what
happens with wages and whether there's
indeed a you know recession in the
future it's just weird we don't hear
much about that from the government and
to essentially is what we're seeing now
a byproduct just briefly of the Whiplash
from trosonomics to now a very fiscally
conservative government I think you know
I think it is yeah I think a lot of a
lot of the you know the tax Rises that
we've seen the kind of you know they are
the government is trying to be
everything that Liz trust wasn't and Liz
trust was talking all about growth she
was talking about about tax cuts but
unfunded tax cuts this government's
trying to do it very differently you
know it's still the conservative
government but it's trying to it's a
totally different strategy to what they
had before some people would say that's
kind of thrown out the baby with the
bath water because you do need some sort
of growth strategy others would say you
need to rebuild credibility and where we
probably are is somewhere in between
those two poles and it's it's very
difficult right now to see how the UK
can kind of you know get really strong
growth uh given just how how tough the
numbers are on on inflation on the cost
of living for everyone okay is it not
quite the positive ending we want sorry
no I mean it might not be hideous as
always it may not be hideous but we'll
take that thank you very much as always
Ed good to see you and and Kenneth and
Lord thank you very much indeed for
joining us
thank you